dans la marne le moulin de valmy symbole
des luttes révolutionnaires n'a pas
résisté à la tempête dans tout le pays
en fait on ne compte plus les dégâts qui
sont extrêmement spectaculaires alors
qu'un nouvel avis de tempête est
annoncée pour ce soir la sécurité civile
recommande surtout de ne pas sortir
voyez ces images commentées par hervé
brusini quatre morts le calvados
dénombre aujourd'hui quatre victimes
jour même de noël ce fut une ferme qui
s'écoulait sous le coup d'une
mini-tornade une femme de 51 ans et un
homme de 39 décédé sous les décombres
une fillette de 4 ans est grièvement
blessé aujourd'hui un homme a glissé du
toit qu'ils tentaient de réparer une
femme a été tuée sous sa maison arrachés
par la tempête routes secondaires
bloqués cent dix mille foyers privés
d'électricité
et ce soir une partie du département qui
est sous les eaux
160 km/heure à colmar et dans le centre
de l'alsace autant dire que la région a
été soumise à rude épreuve deux blessés
graves sous le clocher de cette église
par miracle aucune victime sous celui
mais deux femmes ont trouvé la mort une
branche qui vient frapper une passante
et la noyade pour une autre surprise par
la montée des eaux
ici les rafales de vent se sont
engouffrés dans la barre d'immeuble cité
des pétrels alors brutalement vécu
l'angoissé d'une véritable tempête
cheminée ce bâtiment juste au-dessus
bâton besson voulait des volets des
vitres cassées et puis g20 on a essayé
de mettre la table au travers la fenêtre
pour tenir les fenêtres qui bouge
énormément
par précaution on a évacué les 150
personnes qui vivent là la bâtisse
montrait ses premières fissures et du
pouce de vitry-le-françois ont retrouvé
dans le gymnase du vieux-port des 350
passagers du train budapest paris qui
venait d'être stoppée à reims la
violence du vent a dévasté tout ce qui
ne pouvait résister aux 150 km heure de
cette même tornade submergé les fonds
filles ont reçu plus de 3000 à peine les
160 hommes sur place ne suffisait pas à
la préfecture une cellule de crise tente
de gérer la situation plus d'électricité
voies de communications coupées et
surtout un nouveau coup de vent qui
s'annonce pour ce soir